All right so as you know I had to put
yesterday at the end of the day I got it at
1:47 clearly I'm going to wake up in the
money as long as the market remains red
The question becomes it open will not add
open at 8:45 when my system says it's okay
for me to make trades will I be looking for
put positions or call positions for this
week with the other half of my money and to
be honest with you I don't know
So right now we're just going to sit
As well don't be alarmedSome people pay me
back so I was able to.
Add that to the account so now we're sitting
at 450 it changes nothing
It's just you know you're watching my
finances soThat's how that shit better.
She
Agents working to
Download my repos from GitHub and improve
test coverage
The full goal of the project is to get them
to do it and me not to do nothing so I can
sit back and free while they're working
Play on the cell phone a little bit
That's why people pop in and you know
sometimes you don't see me you only see the
agents I just happen to be showing my face
today because I was being social
Yeah
I pretty much come I pretty much created a
command line tool to allow them
To message each other
And the way it works is pretty simple it's
just pie Ido GUI
And a command line tool that allows themTo.
Paste a message to a specific spot
Yeah man
Bro I apologize you got to understand I'll
be having my spring up for weeks and nobody
will be there I just stop paying attention
I just happened to like I heard the keyboard
todayCuz I have it set to wear chatty lets
me know when you message me.
I just don't be paying attention I heard it
today though I was on time
So what about you man I've been trying to
like reach out and
I've been trying to reach out and see what
everybody's been working on manWe'll get
what you buy coding.
Or what are you coding you might not be a
ViberI want to disrespect nobody.
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah let meLet me help
real quick first. Let's make it worse.
Then let's cut on the light and make it
better
Man procrastination be the worst I'll be on
it I'll be on it bro I was dead but don't
even be on purpose like I caught on YouTube
To open up a stock app at 7:00 I didn't open
up the like the commentary until
8:25
Oh I cut it off and that's how they do
meThat's so disrespectful. And you know the
saddest part.
I probably got it cut the whole damn stream
off to make the filter work again cuz I
ain't fixed that yet that's actually sad
I mean I can cut on the regular camera
that's no problem
Why what's wrong I can always help you
trying to study bro you know we got AI in
our hands
But I'm pretty sure in this interview is you
can't use a how does that even work
Cuz like say for instanceYeah.
Maybe I'm missing it maybe I'm missingAs
soon as.
As soon as I say AI this is going brother
got four peeps taking my interview when they
popping me off
No for real hey you do what you got to do my
boy
Don't disrespect me in front of my new
friend
Ooh it didn't disrespect me I well it did
cuz I got a bird chest and you can see it in
this but I ain't posting that until I till I
fix it how do I fix it
Let's go with this effect cuz that effect
was not it that was not it I was not
comfortable showing myself
Can't help it okay you know what you know
what
Ain't nothing I could do about me but this
is me as hell
No on God I ain't what you don't know is
this another screen up and I got four other
agents going so even though this one agents
running right now I really got I really got
five agents up and going right now
They're all working on podcast just fixing
stuff
Yeah I'm a menace bro I'm about to I'm about
to make the project I'm about to make the
project adaptable to Lennox so I can get my
laptop in and I'm going to add four more
without even like disrupting my computer
problem cuz at this point like I can't add
more agents by adding a monitor cuz my
computer sucks
But that's you know
I also be leaving it running 24/7 and having
agents running while I'm sleep so
That's the coolest part is I have an agent
resume system so I have like a workflow that
I pretty much been working on with the
agents
Bro hey hey I'm talking a brick bro I got
only got 16 only got 16 and on God like
sometimes I can't even
I can't even do nothing cuz it's it's rough
like everything's freezing everything's
trying to close bro what nah nah nah yeah
hey hey why you playing I'm talking I'm
talking about my shit I'm talking about my
shit like it was at the best computer they
had in the building like
But it's still not good enough
That's what I get I should have went to
Amazon don't go to them Mom and Pops I'm
sorry to say it we done with them they
wasn't good enough the best computer they
had still need an upgrade and I don't even
got like I can't even train ml models so
Once again like I'm talking like this a
cheap computer I spent 1200 on this computer
setup
It make me mad almost
None the part not important so what you did
what you what you can't see is Agent I know
I know
But it's cuz the door monitor set up the
guys like he always sucks me up when I have
my laptop blah blah blah he got me he got me
he got me okay okay America he got me
I'm a sucker but I don't mind cuz there's a
mom and pop at the end of the day what I do
a little bit cuz I probably could have got a
better I probably could have got a better
computer on on Amazon but you know Jeff bezo
don't need no more cash I hope that man feed
his family
Now let's see when you popped in I'm
currently working on this implementation for
the agents to be able to
Go to request consultation
Okay so first first we must we must get to
the point that I'm so cheap on pay for
nothing nothing at all well except for
charge EBT in cursive I can't help but pay
for them right
And that's why I like the that's that's why
I like cursor cuz
All these options but either way I build my
own little filter system it's on GitHub
previews you can download it probably
doesn't have a requirements text cuz
apparently all my projects that I ever coded
I refuse to make requirements that TX files
Yeah yeah that's a cardinal sin bro I'm
going to put it on the twitch by when I make
one I started working on hold up hold up
hold up cuz the agents were working on a
twitch by overnight like two nights ago
let's see where they're where we are on that
can I get agent one
Start the switch but
And I hate showing people stuff when they
get here cuz my stuff all I swear to God my
stuff never work in practice in front of
people it's like the mechanic it's like the
car it's like the opposite of the car right
that you bring to the mechanic that no
longer broke my shit work perfectly until
somebody else watches it my projects are
that cat wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I think it's losers my shit work perfectly
until we watch it until we observe it yep
yep
I'm sorryI ain't got no sense.
Oh I could slam it down there ain't really
messaging everybody broSo I could break it
down into one.
And then just act like this is a agent for
Now let me go up there if you better start
you better you better be in the chat switch
back don't embarrass me
No I always embarrassing me
Heck yes and if you can't find nothing else
to do man help me figure out how to
I got my screen up I can't talk and listen
to myself I hate my voice
Yeah and if you can't find nothing else to
do man you can always join me on this
project to automate cursor you know you can
have your agents trying to work overnight
listening to your workflows I'm really
trying to get this project out of a it works
for me stage into a scalable Solution that's
why I was telling you about that Linux thing
no doubt but with nothing else go have fun
cuz that this is what I do for fun
And most definitely keep checking back man
I'm interested to hear what you end up
working on regardless of if it's this
project or another project
I like
I like motion I like hearing people doing
anything you be building a Tetris Battle at
which I did but you could be building a
rival Tetris Battle lap right and then my
agent can be training to battle your agent
Oh no oh noOh no Donuts bro I can't even
read cold stop stop stop stop no. No.
I'm just creative
Yeah yeah I'm not smart I'm not smart I'm
just creative
And we could create together especially if
you're smart I need smart peopleWhere's my
camera.
Just playing I know it's right there I need
smart people
Yeah good cuz I'm embarrassed I might get
hurt man but I'll show you it though let me
just let me show you my GitHub I'll get you
the link real quick I lost money on Tesla
today we don't move we don't want to talk
about it let's let's
Another subject broI called it wrong okay
okay.
And I'm stubborn too I'm still in the
position we probably at $200 lost today
Now where's my profile let's get him my
profile
That'sIt.
It's not this one bro do not be confused
this is why I'm fixing I'm sorry I'm so loud
I can't help it when I finally do start
talking apparently I like yelling at people
but this is not the streamer tools this is
like my first attempt at it even though it
was updated two weeks ago what we're looking
for is this one the way oh no
Oh no I don't know where it went no more
Okay I ain't going to lie to you that mean
the agents archived it I ain't go lie
Okay I'm not going to lie to the agents
hella archived it and I have no clue what
they do with it
I got to go ask him what they did some other
stuff
But it's no problem though if you're looking
for it I'll make you a quick little repo
just so you could quickly find it like on
some stuff please understand I've just
implemented the ability for them to operate
my get so we don't have proper proper
protocols for how to operate in the Swarm
brain so everything's new in this aspect for
the Swarm don't judge them this is why this
is why
I need people to help me because I told you
I'm not smart I didn't even think about if
they're editing my GitHub then I'm going to
need to know you know what they did when
they edited
And it better have been good archiving too
like now I got to go check on them because
They they lowkey just archived a tool I
actually use like regularly
Oh yeah but no no because I use it because I
use it regularly like I use it so regularly
I could actually find it like I could dead
ass just file share it to you like that's
how that's how regularly I use it it's here
that it's here that it's called B tuber B
tuber I don't know why I say YouTuber but
that's what we called it it's ugly but it's
got some tests in there and it work and the
way I run it is with this little cold right
here this little man
Webcam filter cuz I do the pyqt 5I got it
down on notepad cuz I ain't once again.
I'm not the brightest bulb in the box now we
just got to figure out how I share this if
you if you will let me stop being lazy
Another one wait waitI got to take it off
for.
I got to take it off for half a second at
half a second I have a second and I'll drive
back okay
See just go expose me like this boy you
better not be no hacker I don't want no spam
okay you got my email there you got my email
I'm sorryShe's. She's.
Going to give me a second at least I didn't
expect it to be so reactive like
Any other time I swear to God it would have
took
Yeah that's me that's me I'm way more
interested in my projects than bugging and
messing with people
But the whole thing is starting to actStupid
so I had to.
Close so farIt's really messing up over
there.
But now my plan is I got another GitHub cuz
I ain't going to lie to you
I just recently once again okay you got do
not judge them they just got introduced to
my GitHub so long story short
I got banned for spam
I let that one sit in for a second
And they defenseThey didn't know it wasn't
okay to send $750 commits at one time.
Yeah man baby girl I'm from Texas okay so
because I'm from Texas I chop and screw
music well not because I'm from Texas but
I'm from Texas and I chop and screw music
yeah that's the best way to put that
We need to debug this let'sI need to do.
Oh no it's cuz that's where a lot of
hatsThat's all.
Let me get a shirt on man let me get a shirt
on
With nobody in my room at first you know so
I was comfortable I was comfortable
I'm too skinny to be walking around with no
shirt on online with people watching it's
making me subconscious about my chest
But now we family you didn't seem to have
naked
Switch but it's debugging
It's the message call back is failing
So wait wait wait you like that yeah you
know who I got that other one from cuz see
this one I wanted it to look like it was
cartoon based but the what's up Sam going to
head out got to go you look like it's
getting to work I don't know why
Yeah I actually got somebody in the Stream
right now when it does it feels good cuz you
know somebody that understands that feels
that feels good bro you know I've been
trying to explain that shit hey good news
Boss man says what's up his name is
Is it p-forceOr is it peace.
Both is cool to me actually people are
saying to lie to youMan.
I was thinking like what's that game with
all the dang on bugs that just came hell
divers I was thinking hell divers you call
me people as God damn it sorry for democracy
Thing is yesterday I reached out for some
groups in Facebook for Vibe coding and they
were talking about how they were making an
app for like 50 games right and this is what
let me know my expectations on Aria be too
high because you know these are grown people
that actually develop in this guy was
working on a chess app with mahjong tiles
and like Checkers and right are you dead ass
is like already in mid-development on this
same idea like at this point she's putting
an AI coach into her chest app
So
I need to calm down like I feel bad that I
was like like cuz I'll be mad at baby girl
oh she had to go yeah yeah once I once I I'm
like she she deserves a break good job
She's passing in school she's fucking
amazing that cold and great job
Shit this is her website right here hey boss
man check out her website please
This is her website ariajet.side I want to
say
That site and yeah sorry for not being able
to entertain you I got to get them up stream
right now but this is
What she created right here
Now this is the first time
I'm sorry yeah I see that on camera right
but if I okay check it that's my sister she
didn't realize I had somebody in the Stream
either way
I got Aria site right here this is the this
is the beauty that she was working on and I
was so mad at her for a little bit and then
this one right here Carmen Carmen killing
the game
Hey hey bro whatever that is
No way she did not get it set up she's not
going to like that I'm going to get on here
too I'm going to get on her tail oh and
that's a cool thing too I can also access
the Swarm from Discord right so like
So like I could tell baby girl to go
I'm guessingAnd of course I'm going to be
afraid it's cheese.
Right where is itOkay.
Cuz like I say my stuff is lazier's cat and
every time I try to show somebody that it
work it don't work no more like it worked
perfectly till somebody actually watch it
yeah yeah I'm trying to see like right now
I've never seen that before
Do you know it always done it thoughEvery
time you trying to show somebody.
It's probably up
Here
Outside
Bitch no I'm not getting out of my bed I
ain't set my alarm for no 200 I already told
you this going to try and give you like $200
for that car
Let me text message from the Boston I'm like
you must think I'm illiterate of some shit
cuz I see 300 I don't see no damn too
Okay
Baby my text messages
Which I agree with
No because I saw the text message said no
more than three Let Me In The Box but what
the boss man approved for him was three I
saw it it doesn't so I feel like I still
want it because
What was you going to do with itSo anytime
anything more than the the city coming and
towing it.
This year is that Doug because it's only so
long it's going to sit outside with the
window open on rainy days before that on
figure out there
Available off on a car that can't get pulled
off on
I said but this is this is some of those
things that I was telling you about what's
happening with the
With like my computing power cuz like right
now I got the Discord running I got the I
mean I'm sorry I got the Discord running the
Discord about running I got the streamer
filter running I got chatty BT open twice I
got this heavy thing open
Oh and it's still going higher why is it
when I I got the filter going for the pine
script so that it showcases you know buying
sell signals and this is what makes it
cheaper
Clothes all I wanted to show you with the
Discord is that like baby girl can be
anywhere in the world and if she can type
something like this into the Discord or even
use the Discord View
To actually like not have to use theCommand.
Then she can message the agents but
apparently my computer is trying to break up
right now it looks like the computer
legitimately wants to just
StopSo I don't know if you can hear me or
not. But.
Yeah
That's why I was going to goWhere I thought
are you nice to.
Be perfect I thought I might be freezing on
stream or something to be honest with you
it's not cool we could just put that out if
it's on me I'm straight nothing so I was
already smoking for you I got down here
I need to get more but I'm broke
Speaking of love what's up a couple married
people friends
Send this to a message for we could do a
test message like well I don't want to send
a text message right what I'm going to do is
send a message like proceed
Working onI don't know anything.
Right cuz it's my daughter sending it it's
not me sending it right in this case so she
would send it
Oh Lord this just confirmed it and then
It would not work because because I have to
type message right right cuz like the word
message was misspelled that's user error
I promise I'm smarter than it
But since the
System
But I can't sit there and talk to you if
you're readyYou don't let me hook your
computer up to my sister.
Yeah you can act easily what's up
Your computer from down here
Tonight
Until the damn fuse go out upstairs and she
going to piss you off like it always pissed
off
Or Sam hit that light switch I'm pissed off
right now
Running at one time
What's todayWhat date.
Anything
But I didBut I did want to show you it
working.
So what I'm going to do is just close this
on my screen like this I could just run the
Discord back from my phone real quick
And that's actually one of my favorite
things to do now is
Sit backGood morning me. How much is at this
phone.
Broke on me talking about disco how much is
the things that you can change
Again
I need to know the controller
Is send a message directly to phone light
and proceed work you need something for you
oh actually what we should do since it's
clearly stalled is I could use this to
bumping agent too so like basically all the
things that I come into contact with I just
try to like
Saw and this one actually has a pretty cool
littleWay of doing it.
Yeah like my phone has cleared I'm in my my
computer is clearly just like had enough bro
Anything else and it's like goodbye
And let's bump that so what should happen is
the mile should go down and
Resume the agent right but I can also send a
message however I don't want to send the
message because that spot is Agent Forest
but now I can send a message so let's send
the message to agent one and say hey agent
one
EnsureYou completely. Fixed.
The switch byIssue.
After you finish running
And insure it startsClean without any.
ErrorsWe're warning.
Too
And I'm working on a template
Or the Discord messages and being able to
send Discord messages with the template
So that it always reminds them how we want
them to respond back in Discord because we
made a Discord channel for all the agents is
the Discord up anymore of course not
Of course not because now it's closed right
right yeah but okay so if you look here this
is like our preferred method of
I forgot that I wouldn't post to open
nothing else back up
Here
Illegal lineupYou know you got too many apps
on this line.
But this is the way that I prefer them to
respond
Yep yep I definitely amen I appreciate you
coming through bro make sure you come back
hopefully later my computer won't be potato
and I'll get a nice little restart in after
you do
Then I'll be back up and at it againI really
don't stop.
But I still think like regardless of trying
toAlways.
Always I'm going to get a command so you can
see what all we got done eventually when the
twitch by the time you come back to Twitch
better be working with the command I just
told you about
I don't care when you come back and see if
you come back in 2 hours it's going to be
doneThat's the hope.
That's the plan I'm trying to get the work
clothes to where they work like that like
and once I just like I can have all the
agents continuing stuff with the resume
prompt thing but it's not working right now
and neither is the message template and
that's my biggest problems that I'm trying
to solve
I'm not even really concerned about the
GitHub protocols but I also have that Avenue
really got to start writing all this stuff
down
Oh brother I promise and by the end of the
day I'm going to upload the working version
it already works it's not it's not kind of
working it did all the way works and I'm a I
just want to set up a requirements text so
you don't got to fight through figuring out
all the dependencies
It's just people came in the room that's all
I apologizeI got distracted.
But these my family and I mean like I don't
come everyday these people show up all the
time
Respectfully though I'll catch you next time
Big Homie
I thought it already did I know he had any
message but yeah
Still can't believe I lost that man I'm so
stubborn y'all I'm still in the position bro
that's how stubborn I am bro like I like for
real I can't help it I can't it's it's in me
it's not it's not yeah
Did you followMe.
No I'm actively sitting here and I only did
I not follow my plan Sam but I'm telling you
I didn't follow my plan and I'm currently
not following my plan as we speak and I'm
sitting here not following my plan that's
how I be that's literally bye you amazing
person but one thing about it one thing one
thing for certain two things for sure
Whether I'm rightOr wrong this exact same
feeling.
And so I have to have that same energy
Full face either way I hope that when it
systems actually proven I'm rightI could be
this bold.
No like for real for realCuz it's hard for
me to actually close that position.
And that's probably the best moveEspecially
seeing as how.
The last four times I've said that
todayWould have been a better time to to
leave the position.
S like yeah I know I'm telling you I'm not
following my plan right but listening you
not listening okay okay we above the the
4:40 line again okay okay so if I wasn't in
my position right now I would be taking and
buying my position right now so in that
situation as long as we don't close above
450 tomorrow I'm Gucci the only thing that
sucks is that I got
Court weekly options for the second half of
my shit I should have just sat my ass down
that's why I didn't follow my plan yeah for
real like on some shit and I can't help it
and I'm so stubborn because of what I just
told you because it's literally the truth
like that's how I feel if I wasn't buying a
position like if I wasn't in my position I'd
be buying my position
So I don't want to sell that if I think the
people that selling that are suckers
I stay in my position and I look stupid
today and I wear my hat backwards and
tomorrow if I'm fucking wrong I get out I
accept that shit cuz that's just what it is
we'll be wrong we could be wrong but we not
going to stay wrong
And I think that's acceptable behavior now I
think that is following my plan even when it
looks stupid now
You tell me
I've already made my decision I'm going to
be holding this position till tomorrow and
if it's not a good position then I'll be
getting out of it tomorrow I still have my
next check right which is coming up
Thursday so we not it's not like I'm
breaking or losing
We just pay rent
Right so the wrench I get going to sit in
the bank I could technically trade it but I
ain't trying to look bro
Not long as you're not long as I don't come
to you like I need rent after I lost your
rent that's that's all the week no no no no
no but then in that situation then I got to
pay you back like it's different no it's
just different Behavior 25% of it
You know what I'm saying and rent be the
biggest thing all month imagine having
nothing to do it twice
Oh don't get it twist it like I ain't done
it motherfucker police why would you know
but
I don't know about the people ready for that
kind of person like it's just not good
energy and so it's cool if I got enough to I
could do it when I personally got a bank
account big enough to cover the loss so that
mean that it might suck but liquid ain't my
shit and I'm on zero
You said I'm saying but I can't do that shit
until I got enough to be able to liquidate
my shit in at least be at zero if that shit
liquidated I'm a negative then I'm putting
everybody at risk and yang sign up for that
you said I'm saying and I can't I can't
that's biting off more than I can chew
It's one thing when things surprise me and
come up but it's another thing to purposely
going in
I know it might cut it so we might be good
but
NowI am big or getting big on the idea of
like.
Going in on a pot together I've been said
they've been in on that I'm good brother I'm
down for that yeah I know I'm down for it I
always it's not it's no different for me
like it's not anything extra as far as work
for me to do that
In fact we get better positions like that
because the more money we can throw at the
position the safer the position can be and
we can still
See
I would never see that money and the only
reason why I say that
Because I would notWant to take it out.
Any lesson
Okay take something out and it's not
All of them I will be there I will lose my
all my shit before I just empty
All the money is what I'm saying because
that's me too but what I'm saying is I want
to set it up and cuz I I've been working on
the I've been working on that trading robot
too yeah on some shit like perfecting it
even more cuz at first it was reflecting
like
Bro I ain't going to lie to you like I might
have a productLike on some shit.
Cuz I just enhanced that little view right
and
I mean the stats speak for itself I'm just
going I'm just going to read what it say
Okay cuz you remember it was at like 85%
right well now
Now with the improvementsThat me and the
Agents were able to make.
I got it to 95.89% accuracy right and if we
would have done it
In the last year we would have made 75% on
our money
We can algorithm looking to trade that's
like I don't have to
Do anything I can set it up on a workflow
connected to a bank account that
automatically trades and we just fund that
account and we all could have made 75% on
whatever money we put in there and that's
just in
SharesBut it translates away way more in
options.
You know what I mean like death deaf people
I know you online be careful
What does that means
Like who wants to do all the walking for no
reason
Or have you been walking lately
Boy
Get on your headAsian one.
That switch but it's not running
Or at least not in the chair
Use dbdTo fix this problem.
To investigatePrep.
I wish I was playing
But Superman I bet it's doing that and half
a second
I've been thinking I'll be one of them
people they're Superman catch rightAnd he.
Take them on quick and then put him down
quick while when you put put me down I'll be
like
Taking money
Everybody else talking about how fun that
loop de losing the kids next door is
meanwhile I'm like up with seat belt
Way
Catch that money
I see her talk to her hear her voice I asked
her for some money off cash at
To replace what she took cuz I'm not asking
for a loan or a ball buddy and I'm just
asking for you to replace what you took
Over there
I'm not I know how that shit end up working
out it's either them or the Uber fee
And either way every timeI ever get charged
by that shit.
God bless herCuz I don't have Uber number.
So.
If a uber thing come out bitch you did it
again
You've been working on the switch spot
S pussy
Keep away
See websiteAnd we need to move on to agent
number three who is working on test.
Agent number threeXbox One controller.
You know it was crazy
The same time I bought your laptop
Computer thingBut none of the ones have
anything they had any controller.
You got a girlfriendYeah.
Need immigration test on the message sent
herAnd today.
Good morning ClippersAnd images.
Can you please
That's not right nowThat's.
Enchanted appreciated
Machine
Also want somethingExclamation point.
It
She got
I'm going to be like
Traffic City
About to kill it
EBay going to be gone it's a big deal
You know I'm
That really I did
I shouldn't really be no more topics on food
1.15 days I still got it man I love her sky
Life
If it don't make you cry
It's just because the verdict was guilty
don't mean you did it
Most people don't know
Can you believe these Blowfish he goes to
freeze and never receive them seat over need
your Jeep a second you turn that key home
and he holds a week
How come when I see your name
He's not
You want to try to cut your music down I was
trying to say are you back to mailbox key if
she leave it here I have nothing
I don't know if she ever asked me Jackson
today
Better manSorry I miss the best way.
Question mark
Only Human After AllI Need You Tonight.
Hey Google
Mickey Mouse entertainment somebody I
thought I was thinking I've been on that
type of time
I was outside
No not this time
No no no no no no no no I promise I promise
I'm coaching that boy he had to quit again
It's crazy that you just came back I just
got back on topic and found out what was
like preventing the Twitter about from I
mean the Switchback from starting which was
I got that
I love to hear it say it again I'll type it
again
I'm a type it again I want to hear it twice
All right so then let's stop playing with
that man okay
We're not even going to play with you when
the people want something you got to give
them what they asking for
Don't embarrass me in front of my friend
computer
I did not restart by the way I was chilling
with them smoking with them kind of working
on the switchbot and this is why I mean yeah
and this is why I want to know let's not get
distracted and people want some let's give
them what they asking for we going to call
it to me too because that's what it's called
And I get that name from Blaze
No description it'll be publicIt'll be
public I give it a read me and.
Pop up an agentOh fine.
Now let's open the folder no no no no we
need a new workspace
Oh manNo.
The only reason I know about ML and a bunch
of different models is I do Project based
learning and at one point I called myself to
trade and robot plug and I was trying to
find algorithm that was like a reinforcement
learning algorithm you know how they got
that guy online trying to train AI to play
Pokemon while I was trying to train AI to
trade in the stock market and it was a
horrible experience but it was a as
everything that doesn't go good
It was a wonderful learning experience I
ended up learning a lot about the different
ml models I remember there was a linear
regression lstm was my favorite and most
hated random Forest
God is more I remember for the reinforcement
learning I was using a PPO model
All in all it failed because
All in all it felt becauseIt's no.
Linear wind case for like stocks so what I
mean is the
Tomorrow the feds about to come and it's 90%
that they're going to increase rates and
that guidance is going to be hawkish and so
yeah yeah yeah oh I didn't even see I've
never seen naive bass but I do well does
that have something to do it like that but
be Asian optimization when you're trying to
What is that for
When you're trying to identify what the
agent or is that shop is that shaft
All I know is that's optimizing the the
parameters yes parameter optimization
Okay you got to understand that that was
like my first project when I did AI man
Cuz I was coding right before I became cool
like right before and then like when it
first came out I was like bro like I'm
talking when they were articles of people
jailbreaking AI dungeon for like coding like
that's when I like was coding coding and I
was trying to like do this syntax or
whatever and it was hard for me I couldn't
understand it but then we got these AI
agents oh man oh they got these AI agents I
was on fire and I unlocked it what I thought
was a cheat code man
Okay back then I was working on with the
cancer right but when I got right right back
then I was trying to call myself Soulja Boy
of Chad GPT bro on God on God I was calling
myself to chat the Soulja Boy Child ABC okay
okay okay
Either way
Not just that like I was working to try to
make a cursor when cursor before cursor was
cursor and I ended up not feeling I mean not
not succeeding obviously but man that yeah
yeah
Either way it doesn't matter because I was a
unsuccessful coder until AI came out and
then AR bridge the gap of what I couldn't
understand with
With the syntax and so or not necessarily
couldn't understand because I could get
through it but I was like one of those
people that would go
Those people that would go to it was a web
it was a website called like stack Overflow
and different places on Google you could go
and just pretty much copy code and go back
and forth with people to get answers and so
I'm just copy and pasting code I used to
call it copy paste coding right and then
chat GPT came and it was like well now I
don't got to wait two days for somebody to
come up with an answer to my problem like I
could dead ass take the debug terminal and
send it back to chat GPT right and like it
start getting to a point where I don't even
have to ask questions anymore so like at
that point I start working on a conceptual
understanding I'll go through python
tutorials everyday just like learning
different aspects of python you tell me a
library I want to find out a project to use
it like I I love this stuff bro and and
coming up with errors that like the
Couldn't understand all cuz they haven't
always been this Smart Bro they have not
always been this smart and they're still
stupid don't get it twisted like you think
they're smart until you let them run
themselves they're really retarded but if we
can get like the beauty of my system is as
context Windows get better my system's going
to get better as the agents get more
features my system will get more better more
better hot because we're just automating the
agents
Plug in an advertisement whenever you can
dream OS
Okay so that's what you got to stop doing
though Papa if you want the people to get
what they want then we got to let me work so
I got to cook all right now what you do here
is just silently don't say nothing until I
do everything that's just it cuz I'm going
to keep moving until I get distracted with
something else and if I distract myself
Didn't bring me back bring me back to what I
was doing cuz I do that quick I ADHD my
sister came in a room I forgot I was
screaming
Then you came in and I forgot I was texting
my friendOkay so now. I don't mean it
literally.
You do what you wantBut as you see we're
starting to get stuff oh don't potato on me.
Don't potato meNo french fries.
See it is running it is workingMaybe I
should cut this off.
Okay and at least I also seen that so
there's an error with my status change
monitor which is preventing my resume
prompts from sending to the agents which is
good in this sense cuz I don't want the
agents resuming right now if the resume
prompt were to send off like it was supposed
to at this exact moment it would send to all
eight agents this location is not correct it
would then mess with this you see if it
would then when it would go to press enter
all the apps will close
Best thing to do in this situation is either
waited out or I really should have just
restarted the computer I really should have
did that but it's it's going to work its way
through
When it's really going to give up on me I
can't control the mouse
SoWe're Gucci for now I just.
Got to get a better system or actually you
know what
I'm going to go through and check and see if
we have any memory sinks or leaks
Elites better at drawing extra computing
power when we're running these apps just to
make sure that we're like closing processes
properly cuz I have a lot of stuff running
so I don't need extra processes going
All right now tell me you did not perfect
all right
Man I'm trying to be all difficult
ButFacebook.
It does let me do it like that right
It hella lets me do it like it does not let
me do a little fucking my thinking about
I'm trying to think of how do I push it as
wellTo this.
The easiest
You have to add myself to the repo first I
think I have to add myself to the repo first
so let's add me to the repo
How to go toSetting.
Add music collaborator
Alright something I just add my other
profile
Oh I can'tWait I can't add me because I'm.
Bro ain't no way andAnd you couldn't find my
GitHub earlier either huh.
Is that what it means to be banned on GitHub
So they'll let me you oh oh okayAll right.
That actually has big implications for me
It's not band it's not bad I got labeled to
spam account
I got labeled a Spam account
Wow bro that is nah bro
That hurts I ain't even going to lie to you
that hurts
I had to go give me a drink of water andJust
go pee I guess but.
All right all right all right all right all
right all right all right all right I just
had to use the restroom it's not the end of
the world it just means I have to board
everything over the thing that hurts about
that is losing the almost 6,000
contributions this year and the fact that I
won't be able to show people that like cuz
you can't see it or you know like I was
saying
This is when I first started
Go timeline that with AI in the progression
of AI
Is that that okay so now what we have to do
is say forget this
Forget this we just have to say forget this
Is it possible to set it up to be able to
post from two differentGithubs.
Hell yeahLet's switch it. Okay.
So let's just do this the simplest way that
I could think of doing it
And the easiest way I could think to do it
is to go to the D driveRight.
Of course of course of course that would be
too easy right that would have been way too
easy so so we will do is we'll do it like
this
Temporary valveI need a temporary repo.
That can just be any name we'll put it in
hereNew folder.
ProfessionalGitHub.
Right right rightNow next what we want to do
is we just want to paste this in.
Next what we want to do is we want to open
it
It's under professional get up and then we
want to get up okay but next we can close
you out we don't need this anymore we can
select this folder Here and Now start
working on being able to push using the
other
GitHub SSH okay good no no noSo let's go
ahead and start setting that up.
I cannot believe they're trying to they
trying to cut me off from the world bro
what's
That's almost disrespectful all right so if
I remember how to do this we go to settings
My get up and
Can I run that thing for me so that I could
just copy it and paste it into the SSH key
thingy
Where can I use the GitHub API to set this
up completely
QuestionAPI to.
Set up SSH keysAnd gpg keys.
For the new GitHub since y'all got my shit
band
My last one worked respect
As a serious question
OkaySo to be nothing for the Swarm bro it
didn't even matter.
I'll think it's not me they really can't
But it's about to piss me off
What is this
Hey any problems you haveYou know what I'm
saying just let me know.
I'll go in and I'll get the Swarm to fix it
real quickI only use the.
The filters I care aboutThere are other
filters but they probably need to be the
book.
In fact you know what why playLet's see.
Yeah
The auto optimize parameter feature is
supposed to help with that
I'm working on an algorithm to make it
better so don't judge itThis is.
One of those things
How's the latency all the latency is good I
like it yeah I can send me in shape send me
a shake they ready for me and ready for
sneak attack call them back never know I am
ready to go all right next next
All right what we got the sketching color
Well clearly that wasn't good
Yes to show you what was going down it was
bad
On the floor
The teacher look and put it right back on
him
Said she didn't even say anything
Yeah I need to come get him cuz if y'all
don't come get him when y'all do come get
himHe ain't going to be the same as he was
when y'all drop them off.
So that's
BlackYou need anything.
Right right cuz the moment I feel you out of
line now we got to fight and
I finally see what the teachers is right now
Let's get some of this off my screen guys
I'm not going to lie to you I got a lot
going on
SoLet's just go through each of them
non-stop first one.
Are you running on Linux
Hello
Windows 11 I'm on Windows 10 is pi test not
native to Windows 11
Right I am 110 right let me go check
All rightLet's go check let's let's see what
the agent say.
Cuz that is not the error I just wait wait
waitWhat.
What function are you look look look try
thisAnd you might have to modify it for you
right.
Where is chattyBut try this.
Right right right that's what I'm saying but
soIf you click play right.
Then you could just easily use that as a
template or if you send me the command that
it sends you to
Like that you're running to run
The webcam filter pyqd5.py that's the main
entrance that's the main entry point to this
project
So you have to execute that file to
initialize the GUI
I hope I said that rightI hope I said that
in an understandable manner.
The point is that you're looking for this
file
Okay so the readme phone needs to be
updatedOkay.
That's why I called triple ass up man I'm
also working from cursive mobile
I'll be doing too much
But this way I can update the requirements
file with that model so that'll work out
beautifully in fact it's already began so
now I'm reviewing it merging the pull
request and now it should have a
requirements file when we pull it but since
I'm working in a different domain
All right
So don't you tell that tell it to push it or
pull the changes I just made it to see the
updated read me but that's not necessary I
didn't make any cold well I did make code
changes from that last area that just closed
out the project
I'm going to run it again to see myself if
the
Project still crashes when I try to run I
forgot which one unfortunately so I might
have to just play whack a mole with errors
until I find it
Man I'm happy you came back don't think I
forgot about you either manI was over there
refreshing my.
My twitch token when you came or when
whenever you not when you came in but when
you messaged
And what is it called
Now we should also look
If they're called memory sinks or leaks so I
always just catch all and ask for both
Prices righteous righteous okay so now we
can minimize this one I think I pretty much
got you going that was agent 9 so this one
was working on the get up you can use these
two perfect okay so
My boyNo no no not you.
WhoOkay let's pull out the big guns. Let's.
Bro if this is a dependency issue and I'm
working on dependencies and solving to make
sure that there's no
Obvious problems thenI guess I'm preemptive.
YeahYeah.
So I wonder if
It's definitely and what was your proposed
solution what did you say you were about to
do
Yeah yeah peace peace what do we need an
hour for just ask peace
Cuz that's exactly what the model suggesting
to do
Okay and that really begs the question
what's going on with agent 9
Yeah
You know let me address
I could be a requirements sex specifically
for Windows 11 just saying
I need my vape pen I need
Always gone whenever I need them
Give me a hot 20 seconds not even that long
I hope
Definitely was not inIt wasn't in the car
that went.
Maybe my parents pockets
Boom shakalaka the pants back into woodNow.
Did I miss a message while I stepped out
Wait like a clean start got it got it or you
got past that first air we still playing
whack them all
Oh you know what I'm really interested in
I'm interested in if it'll be able to locate
your your camera or if you decide to stream
to something like OBS if if the virtual
camera will have any issues on your system
cuz I personally had like that through me
through the mud
And you know you never get to hear from
other people using your stuff cuz nobody
ever uses my stuff I make a bunch of stuff
for me so after it works for me I don't
really care about scalability since I'm not
selling anything
And I should be better at that but like be
my business partner then
And you can handle that cuz what I do not
put stuff out but I'll be making stuff
Oh and so if this is the first project on
the board then tomorrow
I guess I should go and have the agents
That's that's actually hard I don't know
what I want to doAll right first let's get
this screen back up let's let's get that
back up.
I don't think it was mine orFeel like. It
was a watercolor.
No I wasn't watercolorI don't remember
looking at this and I don't like the way it
looks let's listen just a little bit.
Oh wait a matter of fact let's not a suggest
it let's let theAuto optimize.
Always embarrassing me in front of my friend
All rightThat's both updates. Get ignored.
So that shit handle
Let's switch the things this is probably
your favorite one the advanced Edge
detection is my favorite for sure
Okay okay I'll wait I'll wait
I'm foolishIt's cuz I click this.
Victory
10,000 IQ
Cause mind you this isn't really for y'all
this is more so for meNancy.
I wish I could get it like
In a better position in a better position
but I can
Yeah but it doesn't matter it's like I say
it's really just for me so let's go full
Facetime real quick and I'll get big View
ExactlyYou know what. All right.
Two
Ant information
Falls shorts
Making my phone
Can you told me a few years ago
Jobs making more money than ever and living
life on our own terms and wins
Control
This is where everyone starts right to
follow you through tutorials or got started
with the responsible CLI app or a basic
server application a compiles it works but
it's not very impressive rights for level 1
projects
Modified from tutorials there's still proper
air handling no test coverage and not much
project structures
A lot of developers end up doing stuff by
step instructions
Applications for our accelerator program
last week frustrating program for those of
you who want to get hired and useful
professionally so if you want the planning
Russell
.com
Real world use cases and production grade
resilience recruiters that you're ready to
work on their systems stuck here because
they feel so close but they come between
this and a wrestling worthy projects
Oh good systematic emerging end of some
ability
Double projects that's particularly
important if you want to put something on
the recipe that I personally coaching
problems in
Law school system decision
Should I build with
Or a block site using my sequel or postgres
as a database for the web server itself you
can use popular Frameworks such as Rocket
activix web and warp or instead of building
your own server you can choose to run your
rust code
In the description
Solutions for managing memory today
Period collection
You didn't have to worry about memory
management because the garbage collector did
it for you now this approach has some pros
and cons the first pro is that it's
Performance and program size and as you can
see here we get all the benefits of manual
memory management controller memory faster
run time and smaller program size safely
It does allow you to opt out of memory
safety with the unsafe keyword but that's
meant to be used sparingly as you might know
everything in software so the ownership
Time
Good morningIf you have food suggestions.
Long as it equal in a patty melt I do not
care
I'm good for it and if I'm not good for it
take it out of rent yeah damn it
In the way to go I'm good for you broSmoke
with me.
When y'all smoke okay okay that's cool I'm
not sure right now and I can't go cuz all my
money
I am Mr independent I'll be damned I just
really don't want to start up the truck cuz
that bitch cut off on me yeah it's time to
set that all down till I can get that piece
fixed I still ain't got that pizza
It's $90 sitting here
Bro if you can go back there and fucking
find a you show me that shit is not looking
the same as the videos this the peace don't
look the same the whole area don't look the
same if it was
If it was my shit is 2014
Or 2012 either way it pop up for the GMC
videos that they got up there it's a common
issue too so it should be easy but
Because my step don't look like there's
because and and the scariest part is it's
like it's something covering the area and
I'm afraid to like go underneath it you know
what I'm saying
What the fuck
Ing actually he he did he wanted an easier
way instead of doing it from underneath if
he had to have like a pry bar he could have
went from underneath and pulled it out right
but instead he'll hook something and that's
when he realized that that shit was ing and
then we were just going to have to replace
that too it's just like fuck all right if I
hadn't touched that I wouldn't have even
known
Type shit like until it finally gave up
being a great
Fucked up too fuck how we religorated you
can't even read something that's already
been ated
Everyday no way to do it right cuz like
that's what it was hanging off of when they
put it in like
Baby just it was just you seen that
Johnson's family commercial where it's like
you make a left turn make it right you can
hang it up that kind of shit
No but I know that mine said completely cuz
when you stuck on the side of the road
whatever it takes to get your ass home by
tomorrow
At this point we know it's over there and
anytime any issue sound like that it's time
to get a new car
Game
The cup
Is pushing out too much oil so it needs to
be replacing or an alignment or will
rotation Matt and also it could be the frame
hopefully it's not the frame hopefully it is
a alignment yeah cuz the rest of the stuff I
said is cheap that's less than $100 each
week
Download Fool's coverage insurance I don't
mind having it but I just know that's my
thing but then once again I'm not even a lie
to you like after I know the trick you just
got to get that shit to get up late the lot
they're not checking like Daddy be saying
any check
I know that I've heard other people
Get liability and deathDoes it.
Say hey somebody
Not going to ask me do I know who stole my
car I don't know who someone call my car was
just told him
But nonetheless y'all going to pay me for a
fool a new 2015 Nissan Altima that's what I
know because I get a whole brand new car now
like
I do like that but I'm but like I say if I
would have just been paying a liability on
my Cobalt instead of full coverage I
probably still
I probably still have my Co-op
Not it's not that it's just in general
they're like like if I take all the money
that I put not being able cuz when I finally
needed the insurance full coverage right I
was not able to do it I wasn't able to use
it I still had to come out of pocket so it's
not like it did anything for me other than
avoid Insurance tickets and seeing as how I
can't quite I can't calculate that right but
I only was pulled over twice in my car so
two two Insurance tickets
No no
No no no no no no first of all I've already
paid off all my insurance all my tickets
And the reason I don't have my shit nice cuz
I don't know I got to go up there with a
legitimate car I'm not supposed to drive to
get up there I can't do it myself so it's
like the car can't be registered to me cuz
I'm not supposed to have a car or some
stupid ass shit like that right or like well
now the solution is go to a driver's
Testing but I'm not going to hold you I've
been driving for 20 years I'm not going to
sit there with 16-year-olds on the Driving
School Driving that little car that I see
riding around here student driver but I'm
not a student driver
I'm not and then on top of that like what
are we talking about like where does Victor
go
Home
Are good in business that dude at the it was
right around the corner from auntie freda's
house or whatever back in the day the
driver's test thing over there I drove up
there to like get the driver's license thing
and then he was like you already know how to
drive I was like yeah I'm just like not
trying to drive illegally cuz I'm not for
all that like
Specially if I noticed it
Oh yeah that was that was hooking me up back
then like that wasn't the price that was
probably overpriced for back then but the
fact I didn't have to go to the course and
all that
Yeah they can say fuck them cuz I already
had to pay surcharges for driving without a
license
Hey they need to make the penalty supper or
make it easier for me to get the license
test to two Choice staff
Cuz right now I have no incentive to haul
ass
You got to have faith
Yeah
But I did shut upEverybody.
It is interesting to see that the price did
drop another $6 it was at near 450 so I said
444 damn I was helping you is Kiki I thought
the show that was dead with you
It looks like a checkWith the whale was
shaped.
Tomorrow
It didn't even have to go go home no not at
all
Notice that claims thing they've been saying
that shit for like a little minute
You know you still you know you was never
unwelcome
It's not about the number
So I got a regular if I got it right cuz I'm
sorry put you into Bounty Hunter
You see what I'm saying but we can't smoke
like that be what's stopping us and I was
like
Ever since I heard 75% because I get high
I'm not making $75,000 cuz I Get High School
But brother
Station I'm trying red his soul with that
one
Disrespect me on the inside I'm a fucking
Stoner don't disrespect us we've been there
we've been this way forever and you know
what you know what I had a partner come in
and tell me some shit like that and he was
like you know what and I understand why it's
so hard cuz it was like shit when it ain't
nobody was there Mary was there she was
consistency
You going to quit meSure yeah let's go with
that consistent loyal.
AndAlways. Take your pain away.
Have a bad day bro
Somebody I went out with my redrawal is bad
it's about it's about 5 days you have to eat
I can't
I'm trying I'm trying not to just don't
start some angry at you right now but I
can't I can't explain it I can't my stomach
says unless you got weed maybe we not hungry
oh what the fuck am I supposed to do and
it's nothing that solves it like they say
work out eat more like take a walk none of
that shit satisfies the urge you have to
just go until you forget that you wanted to
smoke and that shit sometimes it don't
happen specially that first little weak
If you can make it past the first week
though I ain't going to lie too 2 weeks to
understand
No no no no no no no no no no
Because not not me not me resetting my
tolerance break in my whole body accepts
that is good enough
Oh and can't nothing go wrong on that road
day 7 through 10 or anything goes wrong
Where you going I've been showed up late for
work I need to smoke
Yeah yeah it's that critical
Maybe like 7:00I must accept my account. At
the end of the bed.
Really stormed out the door came back with a
crown
My foot my toes
Yep
My time feel like walking no more once I got
back from the weed man it was so painful
that it was
People after I got the weed and this is what
I had to understand
I just okay soon as I get to the house that
bitch that bitch throbbing oh I'm really
hoping it's a happy middle in there
somewhere where I can like force myself like
cuz I know that I find myself more
productive if I'll do something like I won't
smoke this blunt until after I do like a
thing right like that's good for me right
but I don't always maintain a stick to that
Bro
Bro like the level four really open up
opportunities not just that like if you
really I mean first of all you get the level
three you can go be a commission's opposite
that's 2325 right like it's like I'm just
I'm just not willing to stop smoking like I
could already be making $5 more an hour does
he used to have the like the hook up like so
The hook up like so this ain't even like dry
entry this is I work here he work good put
them on and I wasn't even doing that cuz I
didn't want to fucking just stop smoking
like that and you can't be on your phone in
the prisons like like literally you forget
and you bring your phone you can go to jail
like
I like my phoneYeah.
And that's another one of the things you
could do but like I said no that's level
three level four yeah the level 4 real
investigator private fucking investigator
yeah yeah yeah like I didn't even know that
bro I didn't even know that like ain't
nobody tell me
That's why I didn't let you sit around and
level two that's not we going right in the
level three
Sherlock homie
Bro why you playing that's contracts that's
like you get that Bond you get there behind
you know like my last Bond was said at 5K do
they get like
If they if I know I got there better be
getting a portion of it too
I don't know insert a line you said 50,000
you crazy
Dad how is a classic
State
Yeah that's the one I keep remembering every
time you say lottery ticket I keep thinking
of that shit and I got to like pop my head
back into the Ice Cube shit
Lottery
Rule number oneSpecially if you got a
winning ticket. Sign your name on the back.
Blue black inkThat's just a standard about
even if they did take it.
Inside itThen mistake number two.
You won the ticket and didn't want to get
put on news why the fuck nowWhy the fuck
not.
Go back to the store on the news hey hey I
get a percentage so I need you to come
Because T-Pain
The T-Pain with the work at the start
lighting man whoever got that ticket come on
cuz I need my cut cuz you know whoever sell
that ticket the store get a percentage they
get a percentage of your money but of the
money that's being taxed that's going to be
taxed from the 60 million yeah it's all part
of it right
Now
Because if they have the winning ticket they
get a percentage right cuz they're not
making money off the ticket the state makes
money is off the ticket
Correct so that's itIt's again.
First day I want
I got the ticket I won and I signed it
anybody come for me moving forward it's all
on videotape it's all on video take me you
know who got the ticket we know who won
movie begin me win the lottery get on the
news
I Security in the movie credits
Cuz even if you do take the ticket you can't
can't do anything with this worldwide
And I'm so nice
I'm going to hide nobody but help around the
hood toughest s could be my bodyguard
honestly and we don't hire a couple of
backup just in case but like
60 million you talking about taking no
chances
Close if I don't give you nothing at the
block party don't hit me up later I didn't
forget in fact we're going to have that
moment like they do like the Kings I'm going
to throw out you can come up make your
request
And whatever you get today that's it I ain't
giving nothing else out
Cuz I'm too nice I already know me I'll
probably blow through all my shit that first
day while I'm feeling excited okay cuz the
next day I'm Frugal Mr Frugal coming so I'm
going to give about it
$300,000That's to the hood you know what I'm
saying I got a melee for the fam.
But you wouldn't like in the house with meI
don't know you.
S don't have cameras on me like Jordan
Jordan got Walmart jeans on at Walmart shoes
on
No me
No no I can be a 60 million dollars driving
me a mother fucking Honda cuz who going bro
not me not me fine I don't know but bless me
with that kind of money I might not be like
I might not be able to retire forever but I
bet you one thing my life will forever be
different I will never worry about bills
again
Cuz I go and pay the miles out like rents
the biggest Bill if you pay off your house
what are you worried about your rest of your
life bro like half the month half the month
I'm working to pay off rent
Imagine you didn't have 15 days of doing
some shit like that
30 days to your God damn self cuz the other
one is just like what I want anyway so I was
going to do that regardless it's like the
other 15 cover me smoking all month my
cigarettes my gas if I got to go to work I
don't even guess I don't know where
I got that fucking my first income tax I
worked all of you
I got I got about 4,000Like a 3,000 of that.
$28
My rent in advanceThanks.
Call didn't work maybe like 3 days in a row
after that I was like
I ain't feeling well I'm going to take some
daysI'll be back in a couple of days in a
few days.
I paid up for like 4 months I'm like I'm up
I'm about to pack it for them no words
Just don't worry
It's two weeks later I'm talking to let you
know that's okay it's not a problem it's
it's
3 months
Waffle bill by 4050
Yeah it's cool long as I got about to pay
all my love
You see what I mean $3,000 is fuck you money
you don't need 10 million I'm starting to
click that
$3,000 is fuck you money and if you got it
in the bank and you living on
With 3,000 you Gucci
I'm starting to try and be like that like my
friend said he made a comment to me when
they was like if you had a thousand he said
a thousand okay that's it but mine's three
if you had a thousand in the bank would you
still be mad about what you complaining
about if nothing
And I see what the fuck he meant
I wouldn't be saying anything else bro I had
4,000 in the bank and I can pay you
everything
Because
I don't get it
Cuz Life is Beautiful Life is BeautifulJust
A Simple Man.
But in the hardest part is just the first
thousand
S? the time right but it's getting there you
might have to you might have to learn a
trade you might have to like you might have
to change who you are as a person just to
get that down like a thousand that you don't
own nobody you good that's sitting there
extra
Yeah I dream on it myself now
Me too I'm not done for this year I still
think I'm going to get my goal is by the end
of this year to get to my first 3000 Market
that's my goal right now
Yeah it's only 21 days man but that's still
like you think about it that's $100 a day
Yeah so technically we still in the range
where everybody could be at 3,000 by the end
of December
I'm not even saying that like like you got
to make $100 a day to do that I'm saying
because the way that the stock stuff work is
as we get to about 300 you know you'll be
making at least 150 to 200 on a good day so
Once again once we get to 300 like 300 not a
big number
I was talking to address she said it's a big
number as a man 300 not a big number I ain't
got a check before those bigger than that so
It's very feasible that we could actually do
that shit and that's what I want to see not
only for me for everybody in the house I
would love I would love a house pipe of
6,000 like imagine we sitting here 2,000
each bills paid
And we can get there we can it's going to
happen whatever we come with whatever
whatever we come with whatever we can all
equally come with yeah yeah
I'm up for dinner What's called the King of
the Hill that shit happened
I made that money and so when it was at his
houseHad that bike for. But that Miss
thought it was scary.
Not only that he he went and told his boss
Awesome
A lot to you and put them and go and put my
money in there since you wouldn't put your
money in there you didn't want to put your
money in there so I made you I fed your ego
and I slid right in I put everything I had
on it
And see
What I want that to end up being like like
let's just imagine in the realm of potential
that it goes successfully and we get
$500 each I don't think that's a lot that's
why I do that out there I think that's very
manageable right and so with that allows us
to take our money that we did put in there
out now we run in that shit for free then
Who knows maybe maybe Corey has an idea that
we can then take our money and start pushing
and he's running every day and then we got
two Avenues you see what I'm saying because
we done pushed it and you see what I'm
saying
I'm listening I love that
Song
Income tax come around rightYour sister was
talking about give me a call I was okay
that's fine.
But the car got to be at least $4,000 so the
car going to be at least $4,000 and low on
low on Miles
Pretty pretty new up today she said why I
said because I have an idea to say what I
did do you have I said I'm going to take the
car that you give me
I'ma getting registered my name and I'll let
you know everything get out of that will be
done with that that's good then I'm going to
Want to put my car into the Google pool
where they rent cars to work for Uber
That's
For us how much I'm willing to receive per
week if I do just let's just say please
I just do 375 a week and two and a half
months that'll be that'll be the $1,000 I
made I thought
I take that and buy another vehicleAnd start
doing a fleet.
Doing the same thing
For that just push it againThat's a snowball
if you can get.
Snowball if you can get that price and even
if it's not 2 months like because I don't
know how much somebody will be willing to
pay per week in Uber
It's beautiful especially if we can find
ways of getting the cars that they're
looking for the qualify for cheap which
public auctions is a thing you see what I'm
saying I was I'm also down for going down to
public actions and buying and fixing up cars
again
Said reallyReally is it is up to me like I
thought.
I would take that profile or nothing we
instead of pulling out what we might be able
to pull out two or three depending depending
you go to the right auction with 4,000 you
might be able to pull off with eight of them
Right so and I'm not talking back cards
Like I used to do those public auctions bro
I was doing them I don't know how that shit
go now with the the titles though and the
transfers cuz that was not something that I
was putting into my fees I was just selling
them hoes without the titles Kiki got like
two cars from me like I used to really sell
them but
Once that tell me a week I I would like to
get back in today because the the thing
about thatThe thing about that is.
If we get that many carsAnd run them hoes up
like ain't nobody.
Ain't nobody
And that's the type of shit that I'm trying
to build up cuz this Workshop cool to make
sure that like shit don't fall asleep but
that's what I want to be making my money I
want to go to work for me
I'm trying to get it for us
The same thing if we put our money together
You can get you a car I can give me one and
nowhere
I see it I see it and then not even just
that bro
At the end of the year
Something else that we're doing today
People have on the train ship and we can
actually have some big shit to be able to
roll the dice on a hit of all good 150
because we put about 15 to 20 come on and
you soon so you see the vision of not just
that it checking balances itself cuz maybe
the trades off but then we got extra sales
on that you know like we got five adults in
this house every one of us got a
specialization in something you know
something that I can't fucking find from
nowhere else right and I don't know what
that is because it's your shit I know what
my shit is I'll be down here holding my crap
everyday and I was like even even Sam got
fucking that same thing
That same thing I'll be trying to explain
that to him that's why I wanted him to go
and get big or deep into that sports betting
shit cuz that could also be an Avenue you
know what I'm saying
So right now
You know it's like change just yeah playing
some panties some fantasy looking for things
that you know but when you write you right
and you only got to be right one fucking
time bro
That's it
Right cuz I feel like that's some nice
stable income
We working they bring the car
They paying this shit they got their cars on
fire it's getting taken off it's here now
it's hitting the account
It's just hit me up we not even looking at
this money
Two months later we look back on shit it's
all about this account
And when we start doing all that right we
get LLCs corporations
We don't have to pay youRight cuz you got
child support and shit like that we don't
got to pay you directly we can pay.
We we don't we don't we don't never have to
pay you I mean not literally I mean we can
pay Siri
I won't fucking back with any business if
you don't say it like it's
It's just open so many valves in my head
just now and now I can I can literally just
point and go on One Direction
We got to be with himself and that's harder
to do
Period but what I'm saying is that like I'm
trying to make the barrier to entry as low
as fuck and that's as simple as $20 we all
come up with $20 we got $60 right now like
literally right now and maybe we smoking so
I know we can come up with $20
If you don't mind
Houston something Popeyes and then to home
Walgreens
Situation before I leave
And if I'm leaving now struggling the same
way I came in
The mission was not a secret
Whatever we need to do to get that Wheel
Road we do get the money and we can put it
in there we can see
Will you see that shit just like that like
you big this 3000
We already know what the recipe is you
already know I'm going to let you cook this
I'm going to let you cook this you know the
recipe is thinking about with him though he
ain't going to be like this let me cooking
right now is I really
I'm doubling down on my shit and I don't
like y'all might not be able to notice it
right but I improved the strategy I know you
got the recipe oh and she's not at this
point I got a product
We got about we got about 45 minutes
Minutes sometime minutes
Away from 10 to 12 bands you understand what
I'm saying so that mean
That that margin of error that he is going
through that bitch is short I'm never too
short and it's about there and it's about
there it's one once once once he can break
that bitch and that bitch
I always ask you
I said but what you what you what you need
to be you know what you always told me if
everybody if we can just come up with
everybody together just come up for 25,000
Oh yeah that's that's always been a go if I
get the $25,000 if I get $25,000 we don't
got to do options no more which means we're
no longer limited by
Right which is that thing which on Friday
means my shit expires work zero at the end
if I had $25,000 it would be
And it would be shares and if I was wrong
I'll just hold it I'm 100%
. I never been wrong I hate to say that shit
without like that is my problem but I swear
every time it's not that no I'm saying like
long term like if I was just to be able to
just what I say happens I might not be right
about the time it happens but I'm always
right about what happens I am always right
and so the problem is just simply I haven't
had $25,000 to be able to sit there and
stand on my shit like I stand on my shit and
I'll stand on my shit but I just I'm not
playing the same game
Because like I say my shit expired worthless
you got to be right when you're supposed to
be right with options
With shares you just got to be rightAnd you
can wait for when you're right that's same
for y'all it's not just for me it's
everybody.
It's a lot easier to say Tesla's going to go
down when we're at 480 right and that's the
highest it's been in the last 5 years that's
what I'm doing right now I'm not super
spectacular like over the last few months
450 hit 450 ain't less every time we was
over 4:40 is not Super Genius I'm just
watching the show every time it's over
before they come back down
We're in that same situation today if I
wasn't in the position I was in I'd be
buying this shit right before the club so
that's why I'm not selling same thing so
tomorrow if if the narrative change then
I'll change but until then I'm following my
plan same plan I've been saying and if it
sound like I'm saying something different
than I've been saying then let me know but
if it do then I'm following my plan
And sometimes the plans fail and that's a
part of trade
But I was saying I got this improved this
strategy bro I haven't touched this strategy
in 2 years and I finally fucking went
through and I approved this strategy the
strategy was showing that at first I was
using it as just an indicator does anybody
ever remember me saying that that I only
used it just as an indicator because it
wasn't finished because it wasn't profitable
over a million dollars the strategy had had
only generated like $2,000 right and it was
like regularly that's not a lot of money
over 2 million I mean over a million right
but like if you look at these stats and your
boy done upgraded this shit was 89% now it's
95% now this shit is 740,000 bro I'm about
to turn this bitch into a trading robot and
so it's literally like literally we got
until I can turn this shit into a robot and
I work fast I do work fast yeah I know but
we got until I can turn that home into a
robot man and that's what we've been to be
putting on money on that's why I'm trying to
get people in on this shit and that's why
I'm
And I so it's not going to be me it's going
to be the strategy that I've been working on
for the last 14 years but the yeah cuz I'm
the problem I've been looking in the mirror
saying it's you but I've been trying to be
better right now
Hey I takes the emotion
Now and they let it lets describe and push
through without emotion so when he does get
that get that motherfucker up with money
need to be ready
Next year I promise that 2026 it feel
different it's going to be weird I'm already
looking forward to the day where I can hit
everybody up on my Facebook and ask them to
invest $50 with me that's going to be my
plan as soon as I finish this robot I'm
going to give every single person a chance
to throw 50 to $100 no more no less not
accepting twenties not accepting tens if
you're not in this house whatever y'all got
y'all come with but if you not in this house
on the
Got in this house on the Facebook the 50 or
100 that way it's easy and keep track real
simple and whatever we make we make whatever
we don't make we don't make and I'mma just
let that shit ride and I can't wait to just
see cuz I know what I personally been able
to do with it and I don't follow the fucking
rules so I can't wait to see what it does as
it actually just does what it's supposed to
do
It in the backtail massage
We ain't doing no treatment cuz at the end
of the day we know what we know what the
game is but I'm just I don't I don't
This your special specialty but
My heart is saying yes saying this is it
this is it
And I've been saying it since you been
talking to it I've been explaining this shit
to me and everything like this is it this is
the
This was this was going to change this is
this is what this is where
This is where we going to be looking real
different about this time next year I
promise
I'll be looking real real different nowhere
near the same nowhere near the same it's so
much money
We got to do is open and receive it that is
it
Only let me see all they changed it I don't
know how I feel about this
They changed since it only show the last 30
days but that's still good that's 30 days
worth of trade in
And automatically made 74% on our money and
that's been shared too so it feels options
Yeah cuz I really want to sit together and
get together on like a LLC at Corpus hole up
that could literally bring us the money to
actually start a car business yeah
And Ashley cell parts
I got the Bounty Hunter they can turn into a
business where we could be paying
Other people and he's the contract we got
yeah The Brokerage like a man hey hey you
work with me hey this is what we got going
on
Here
Or or end up looking up and just getting
this nice little security contract as weird
as that shit is you charge them people
$35.45 $50 an hour you see the guard up
there he making you have nicely right 18 you
not up there you charge me $35 an hour to
have an armed guard up there making $15 an
hour per guard
You're not at work what are you doing like
the but it's just a matter of finding that
contract and that's always the case it's
getting that in but I don't that's once
again I told you that's not my strong suit I
identify these opportunities but then having
the guts to go out and be like all right let
me talk to him because I need him for this
contract basically that's why I'm not a
fucking developer now it ain't that I can't
make shit I actually did reach out and God
damn I actually reached out to people
yesterday I feel so proud of my efforts not
trying to get distracted though
You got to let you come I just need to know
today
I'm working in two jobs I'm doing this shit
with me because I knowIt's been a shooter to
me mentally spiritually.
That this financial shit it's
It's it's here to come here
Bro
Hey without work is that show that so that's
why I'm pushing it two jobs cuz I'm going to
work my ass off cuz I got fake
I truly believe that
And just having this conversation again now
it's only confirming with already new and
that's why I've been working so hard yeah
faith without work again yeah yeah cuz I'm
asking God I'm not asking God for a small
little blessing so I understand why and got
it yet it's going to take him a minute to
cook up the football field I plan on looking
out that's my backyard you know what I'm
saying he got a clear space and somebody
else great has to go for me to fit into the
spot that he has to clear for me
And it's okayCuz I'm willing to put in that
hard work I'm willing to put in those late
nights those early mornings.
Somebody else I'm talking to his name is
Scott was talking about buying car lots
He's talking about buying car lots and empty
lots because there's this he was talking to
one of the guys at the poker Hall and they
were like you could buy a plot of land for
like $8,000 and you could like charge the
trailers to park their cars if you can find
like you all for security and then that's
pretty much it right and it's like bro he
makes now he's he has like five or six
places but from each one of those $8,000 a
lot team now makes like 9,010,000 so he's
already got his money back and this monthly
because these guys need places to stay when
they're going overnight and this spot's not
going away cuz even if they do autonomous
cars like they they're still going to have
to have docking stations and your last prom
for this so you're like pretty much you just
move with the times when it comes
If you have to answer everything
I got plenty of ideas I just don't got the
capital if we had the capital and the
Manpower I got plenty of ideas down for like
a fucking box truck and a moving gigs yet
Little bitch ass these cars by we stay in
about anybody anyway love to pay cash let's
get all the money we can off the backend
okay
You know you know black people okay
Bye please
Please
Card I don't even work no more I don't know
what's wrong with it won't start then we
just come with our key oh no problem cuz we
got the fucking started cuz they got kill
switches
If I'm correct the one
Dangerous for you
Don't know
In 2 hours
Away
This painted
Did you go pick that up for meI appreciate
it another one another day of the job.
It's up to you it's just business
With the car so you can just go just fine
With different avenue different incomes
different shit than that
Steak and Shake was like 13,000 last I was
looking at itIt's a franchise.
But I'm just sayingWe can all work there
everybody.
Hell yellow at the same time
Really supposed to have a say so and stocks
like in you know what I'm saying that's like
a real franchise like
I don't know if they do that anymore but I'm
saying when I might be a old but when I
start working doing the restaurants and shit
like that that's what they was doing like
McDonald's and shit like that and I always I
always say that
WinCo Wingstop on me a Wingstop on Wingstop
so bad
I won't be a Wingstop so I know you got to
pay set off like 2026
We would have to say
Didn't stop
Whatever appointment whatever need to be
fixedAll that miscellaneous shit to give us
to get us started but once we get started
shit.
Got a couple of corner stores and for at
least right around here but I don't know if
you got that one but I mean okay
Only thing I'm saying is I just want to make
sure like with
With something like that no no no I don't
have a problem to be watch out for it cuz
the ones in our near area just went out like
that chance then you know you don't want to
throw a Chinese restaurant right we're at
the Chinese restaurant just went out of
business
You know what I'm saying so same thing for
the corner store right there the corner
store next to the mechanic shop yeah that
bitch used to be a corner store over there
it's not there no more so I don't want a
minute so I don't want to end it used to
have a gas station too a little low gas
station
Single cigarettes but your mother fucking
getting it right there
I know all the reason why I know this cuz
I've seen that shit when cuz that's what I
start first first started getting them to go
out that broke them games on white peach
that's why I started getting them from right
now
About to put up don't let me see yeah yeah
I don't say shit I see shit though that
ain't my bed is don't give a fuck but you
know what I'm saying
You couldn'tGet in that bitch too.
I remember I used to buy the$2 pack of
cigars from.
It's cigarette cigarettes and I used to cut
them hoes in hand only smoke half of it I
forgot what themes of supreme
But none of that bitch ain't there
everything else is kind of like it's like
double the world cuz you know once I feel
like that's the once I hit what's the name
I'm there once I hit that on
ThatWhataburger right there.
Whataburgeries
Doesn't like
Let me take that back I'll go as far as the
hair store but I don't really want to walk
to that ship that shell feels like too far
away from home
It's a lot bro
I'm just waiting it's going to get busy I
just look at it like thisDon't be better in
the morning or better.
The next 30 minutes
Thank youIt's funny how. What you doing now.
Like be on the computer and shit that shit
keep your mindOccupied. You know what I'm
saying. It keep you.
Doing with youDon't you.
But then when you ain't working
And when you are working that's kind of like
your peace of mind like
I don't have I feel like I don't have a
peace of mind bro
I'm just being real with you bro I'm that's
what's fucking with meLike.
It's just everything broMe not working like.
That shit is easier
People people
I take that if I have to likeSo how do you
get into that.
I don't know
But I don't want this check be like
What about social securityYou know what I'm
saying.
So retirement when I get you know what I'm
sayingYou know don't you get a check for
everything.
Or does it eventually just stop yeah I do
but them s talking about cutting that shit
like right
Right now let's be wearing nothing really
last forever you know what I'm saying
Kind of grandfathered into a good system on
that but I'm not telling you not to be
discouraged not to discourage you from you
not doing something I'm just saying like
that not to live in fear cuz that's a
horrible way to live yeah just in general to
add to anxiety and stress I'm just thinking
of just as a person how it would be if I was
worried about
A check that I've gotten forever and stop
and comingYou know what I mean like.
It would be like
That was just throw me off I couldn't find
out your inheritance like
You know but but like I said
I want to talk about the the piece of mind
cuz that that's kind of crazy if you can't
get a piece of mind
Because you're not understanding that you
were wrong by the way I don't when I go to
work I don't get a piece of mind I hate
going to work right cuz at work people
constantly talk to me I'm at work I can't be
on the phone while I'm not supposed to be
right so I can be on the phone but I got to
sneak to do it type shit right and even when
I'm at my my job I'm still working on my
projects that's my my project let me use the
phone that's why it's running when I'm gone
cuz I'm sending messages to the agents but
that is my peace of mind that's why I'm
always doing it right cuz I tell I've been
told you find something you're passionate
about and so when I look in I think you're
passionate about playing games cuz you play
the game so if you can't get a piece of mind
while playing the game
Then you need to find something else to
doWhat would that be.
Something that generates moreMore.
So you're not doing fulfilled not at all bro
and that's why it's hard for me to stay on
games now
Because
At the end of every action that I do I want
it to end with a producible output than my
family can benefit from
You know what I'm saying so each one of
these little apps that I'm playing with that
I'm messing with I plan on trying to
monetize and building into a business when
I'm sitting and I'm chilling with y'all I'm
not just smoking I'm talking about business
ideas and how we can start
Every time I'm talking about something it's
hard to me you got nothing but something
like this longWhere is it.
Cuz we don't know it's my name
Oh Lord
I'm saying you can't be getting off on
people your hair like that
Remember you say you how you talk you crack
jokes you can't quit jokes with your hair
like that
SeeI know you can do it.
But whatI've never heard of that.
Who worked you got me on recordingI don't
even know where the iPad is. What's the
outfit.
It's like a phone Booker
So you just want a big phone you want one of
those old big phone fixed to have
You ever heard of itBut I think. One of
those things.
Interesting
Yeah
So I got a high stuff to do
What what do you want
A what I told you I don't know what that is
I've never heard of it
What
OkayYes nice yes yes no yes.
I don't know what time upI don't know what
you talking about.
You just keep confirming that I will have to
It's too early
Merry Christmas
That's a lot of hellThat's your hair.
See you'll be able to take your hair out
like that
I'm going to go to the store
Sponge
But yeah
On the way toStart a little projects.
Like and like I said it don't got to beCold
and projects like. We at the age.
WhereWe need to start.
Influencing other peopleLike building teams.
Right.
And so the first thing we got to do is we
got to become a team amongst ourselves
Right and then
With the team is only as strong as its
weakest link and you don't want to be the
weakest link or the person contribute in the
least right
So
That requires you to level yourself up but
in your own domain and you got to find what
that is
Right so like I want I want to do like a
meeting
And we can have this meeting as regularly as
y'all want to have it like honestly butOnce
once a week.
I think we should get together and just talk
aboutThat kind of blame. Where we come
together as a.
You come together as a team to do something
And we might not have nothing this week
right but like let's say we make the goal of
that meeting to put $20 in every time
All right well every time we come together
that $60We come together four times in a
month.
That's $240You know what I'm saying.
4 months we got a thousand
A year we got 3,000 miles the money we got
to come up with the plans we got to come up
yeah we got to come up with the plan too
right cuz that's the biggest thing right now
is we need we need plans that we can
actually Implement not stuff that we like
for instance and it's not offense to his
idea or even my idea right but we need
something we could do now that we will all
actually do right cuz if we're going to do
the coating or the trade and we did it was
going to do it's an in his idea is a bigger
barrier to entry right cuz now you talk
about buying a car I'm not I like that I do
because I'll be having 3,000 that I just be
blowing cuz I'm stupid right so why not put
it into a car every time I get to 3,000 buy
a car start over gets 3,000 by a car start
over
The year I still have my money I just got
cars now right and if that's even $150 a
week like that's still $150 a week you know
what I'm saying
Cuz I'm saying
Thank you
I don't know if I want to actually do Uber
though that's not that's the thing but I do
it yeah yeah that's that's why I like his
idea cuz I know there would be people who
don't have cars that would want to work in
the Uber and if we're like imagine we're on
there and we're charging lower than
everybody else cuz that would be my goal
like I might not have the best car on there
but mine 200 200 a week is still $800 a
month
Like that's damn near rentYou know like. Cuz
what's running a thousand you something so.
Imagine you got two of them now you getting
paid $600 a month cuz the car is already
paid off you know what I'm saying
And then they start paying you to buy
another car you start getting to a point
where every few months you're buying another
car for you know it
We stacking that's why I was telling about
that that's all saying about that LLC man
that way it don't fuck with your check that
way you can still get your money or still
have access to it like I would love to start
next year where the LLC cuz I feel like
that's the first move towards
Us actually putting something together
But when we do it I want to see three
different business plans right cuz with
three males that run the heads of the house
So we all got to have a branch in it cuz
eventually I want to turn it to a S
Corporation and we have three DW I'm sorry 3
dba's doing business ass Sam or whatever you
want to call your shit doing business ass
Corey or whatever he want to call this shit
I'm going to call my shit Free Ride
investment so I'm going to call my shit
Southwest
Right right but I want to like I said I want
this to be something like I don't know that
I only say that cuz I get interested in
business and I hate that I do that right but
like if you want producible results then a
business or a business idea will get you
there right if you looking for a fulfillment
what's more fulfilling than turning our
lives around and fucking making our lives
better nothing is more fulfilling than
making our lives better you see what I'm
saying that's all I want to do but see
Then we got to sit down and we got a
brainstorm on what we would actually do to
get some actual money you know what I
noticed from
Going as I wasSitting here to talk to you.
For a reason bro. Like that shit is crazy
because.
I have a deadlineBetween like.
Her mother
Is about to give me like the full custody of
smart
Girl I'm saying like she's at that age two
to where you know what I'm saying
She want to move out of town
And she wants my daughter's name is time for
me to break something like
She don't want to have to be somewhere else
and have to really worry
You know what I'm saying about raising the
kid it should see it is what it is no I
ain't mad at you know what I'm saying
Live your life go ahead cuz you didn't stop
me from living mines because
You know what I'm saying I still married to
woman of my dreams while still being able to
take care of my kids so you didn't stop
nothing cool I'm happy for you on it
SoNow it's time for me to be like okay I
don't I'm not going to even attempt to try.
To deal with my life would be having child
staying with me and being married on top of
getting the God damn check no
It's not enough for me noNo.
So I need a job if anything about the job
because I don't want to be on that long
I got to get it likeI love some a lot right
now.
And I'm 37 years old
3 years I'll be 40 do I want it yeah what
the fuckNo.
And I realizeEven though if it come I could
be without it thank God for that.
It's not meant it's not really meant to live
on it's meant to supplement
And then it gets to a point where
They try to they try to put it in a
situation where if you're on it
And you supplemented and you supplemented
too much then you put you get penalized so
it feels you know what I mean and it's scary
because then you got to jump and take the
leap cuz now
In order for you to keep progressing then
you got to be like fuck that shitAnd let me
tell you what else too.
Thanks to they will cut that shit off
If they find if they ever know like I was
married
That's crazy
I know one time think of they probably going
to call me and but I ain't where you not
getting your check I'm not I'm not worried
about it
But I do tell her I feel like I'll be on
borrowed time like they going to try to
catch a at the wrong time
All right bet all rightAll right.
What you going to do what they going to say
what they can do shit it's already done
I ain't let that shit stop me the first time
before I said fucking I do
Not stop me now
You know what I'm sayingI'm the same way.
Can I tell you the the belt was leaving the
ash Mark of
It it was an ass marker
And multiple spot
I'm just tired of it I'm tired of it it was
just the way he was crying on the phone bro
I drive myself my whole body went lip cuz I
know you fucking my Corey was like I can't
save you with this one now the mouth one you
mean me popping in his mouth when you talk
back he said he could argue with me with
that one but as far as me getting the fuck
up when he's dropped down like a white kid
and beating your ass you not going to tell
me I don't do that shit when I was doing it
while I was pregnant with your sister you're
not going to tell me right
7 8 months pregnant you I know
You got me fucked up you're not do I need to
show you prove that I do it cuz I give you
an example you don't remember this
You don't remember
Mother fuckerStill holding the bus. And he
still talking back.
And he's still talking about it I'm over his
ass but you talk back shut up that's your
problem the teacher explain to us and she
left that's what piss me off really cuz he
lied to me he lied to me he said the reason
why he got in trouble is because he asked
the teacher if he can go pee and she said no
so I'm just until she said you know what I'm
going to cry even harder right that's what I
thought right so what I told you today she
said no that's not at all what happened and
then she went down the list of things that
happened he pushed Coda he's fucking like
she she tells him to go sit down she allows
them to get up they don't have to always
raise their hand you can get up and go talk
to her and ask her questions but when she
says go to the fuck down he does not go to
sit fuck down he said but
But this but that but
But this this and that and that's not what
you're supposed to be doing that's your
problem and she said it's like he does what
he wants and it's just like well we are we
being on that I'm glad you now are on the
same page exactly we're trying to figure
this shit out too okay cuz he does the same
shit at home but the far falling out crying
on the floor because I beat that shit out of
him
You going to go to the school and do it
You lost your fucking mind not you
embarrassing me at that school like like you
just fall out like a white kid at home and
you don't
You don't do that shit no moreCuz I beat it
out of you. Wrong with it.
I'm tired of it though right but his main
problem is just talking back and not
listening
But he's only drives me not bad but that's
the only bad flaw
Right it's just expressive of itself in in
this world it's not acceptable at school but
I'm also let you know hey like I'm thank you
for letting me know that I made you angry
but the only reason why I made you angry is
cuz you made me angry and every action has a
reaction and at the end of the day if you
don't give me the action that I'm trying to
tell you to do I'm telling you to make good
decisions therefore you going to get your
ass
You can still Express how you feel but I'm
still going to let you know the grill right
that's just is what it is and I don't feel
bad
I just sucks cuz
I never had a school
The Carlos they told me nothing either oh
Ariel everybody accused of stealing some
moneyBut she didn't steal the money.
She already had her own twoSo.
The teacher was wrong and she didn't
apologize no the teacher ended up apologize
and I think she talked about that because
the teacher apologize cuz now her accusing
you were still I don't like that
Great great you didn't do it in the fact
that you didn't get an apology
In between breakish right now
Trying to figure out this what the fuckEr.
Berg
They're just textedIn a remote give me a
little reminder.